this protest has been called by
supporters of South Africa's third
largest party the economic freedom
fighters and they say it's about the
rising cost of living unemployment and
crippling power cuts their leader Julius
malema says he wants president Cyril
ramaphosa to resign he accuses him of
corruption and mismanaging the country's
energy crisis if he doesn't resign what
is your next step protest is not an
event
it's continuous it's not a 21st birthday
party it keeps on rolling we were on the
streets were in the courts who are in
Parliament will continue to fight until
he steps down
[Music]
some areas in South Africa can go
without electricity for more than 10
hours a day the power disruptions are
affecting businesses homes and slowing
down economic growth president recently
appointed the country's first
electricity Minister some people here
say their hope is going to be something
to help ease the country's energy crisis
others are not so confident
people who marched say as far as they
are concerned Monday's National shutdown
was a success in some parts of the
country shops and Banks were operating
normally but in places like the capital
Pretoria there was an increase in
security and several businesses didn't
open there are important Administration
says it's working on turning around the
economy and improving electricity
services
but South Africans who marched to the
presidential Guest House say they are
growing impatient Al Jazeera Pretoria